Now that we've walked through all of the elements of VQE, let's
summarize what we've learned and see how a quantum computer executes it.
We start off with our cleverly chosen reference state, parameterized circuit,
initial choice of parameters and a Hamiltonian.
We pass these to our quantum computer.
Before the Hamiltonian can be executed on the ansatz state,
we need to do classical pre-processing of the circuit
to make it readable by quantum hardware in a process called transpilation.
It's also important to take the most advantage
of the architecture of qubits in the real hardware to get the best results.
These processes are often taken care of automatically so that we don't
explicitly have to know qubit connectivity,
gate fidelities and so on.
Now the task is to measure the resulting state
and estimate the expectation value, which will be further
optimized by a classical optimizer.
This measurement is performed by rotating measurement basis
and then combining the measurement results to obtain the expectation value.
This parameterized result is then fed
into the classical optimizer, which finds new parameters for the state.
Then the process is repeated.
A classical pre-processing creates a new parameterized circuit
and we apply the same Hamiltonian as before.
Note that in the whole VQE process we only change the states
through the parameters which get closer and closer to the ground state.
We repeat this until we're satisfied with the result.
And that's it.
My name is Victoria Lipinska and this was a variational quantum eigensolver course.